i'm dave rubin and it's friday that
means
we've got another friday panel
extravaganza for you
joining me today are the hosts of
slightly offensive
on blaze tv elijah shafer and prageru
personality amala epinobi welcome to the
reuben report guys
thanks for having me dave yeah thanks
for having us all right so we're going
to be talking about
policing we're going to be talking about
race we're going to be talking about
rioting
all of that stuff uh i think most of my
audience
elijah probably knows you so i'm going
to start with the mala here
amala can you uh can you introduce
yourself to the reuben report
crowd and tell them what you're doing
with prageru with your fancy prageru
flag behind you
sure so my name is amulet binobi i am
the
new member of the prageru team i'm the
prageru personality so prager you sort
of put out a casting call to find people
who were giving conservative takes
online and i ended up being the winner
of that casting call so i'm coming at
you from the prageru office in la
there you go and elijah for our few
viewers that don't know you
who the hell are you well i'm not
important enough to get
called on a casting call that's pretty
awesome i got into this by mistake but
no my name is elijah and i
i run a show called slightly offensive
and it is slightly offensive because the
truth uh
unfortunately isn't very popular today i
i kind of uh
do the the bad thing where i insert
myself into situations that you want to
keep your kids away from and i'm talking
about the good old peaceful protests
and riots that we've all come to know
and love and
unfortunately i'm more known for getting
punched in the face by peaceful
leftists and that's not i'm not proud of
that dave but
that's where we're at all right well
let's start right there because there's
obviously a lot going on
right now uh why are you in your studio
elijah shouldn't shouldn't you be out
there i mean we've all seen the videos
you're usually out there during these
things i mean
and and yes you've been punched and
attacked and the rest of it for doing
your job as a journalist
yeah unfortunately i cannot go against
human biology i tore a ligament
in my like my between my quadricep and
my knee
and so i had a hard time walking up
about six stairs into my studio so i
think you know there's a little more
running
involved in riots in protest than like
six or seven steps just in case you
haven't seen
uh those people are so loving they're so
grateful that sometimes you have to
you know run for your life they want to
love you to death so i i'm unfortunately
injured and stuck here
but i will be out for the chauvin i will
be out for the chauvin riots which we
know are gonna happen
yeah which is just crazy in itself like
we know we have pre-warning of riots
even though we're in the midst of riots
right now
uh amelia what would you say is sort of
the general temperature right now it's
sort of you know if you looked on
twitter and i know that's not the
greatest place to figure out the
temperature of anything half the people
sort of think oh this is just the usual
stuff and then the other half are like
oh the revolution
is here what's your take uh it's an
interesting temperature right now i'd
say compared to where we were last year
we're sort of at a simmering point in
comparison but i think when that shogun
trial ends we're going to
head over to a boiling point and we're
going to see more of those peaceful
protests that we got last year so
that's what i'm looking forward to yeah
what do you think
is sort of the line that protesters
can can go to without crossing before it
goes into that
that riot version it's an interesting
question i'm i'm not sure i mean back
when i was working on the left we would
go to protest and it would just be the
signs and the screaming so i'm sure
i associate that as a normal protest but
then we're getting into the realm of
beating police officers and random
bystanders and
setting things on fire and looting
businesses so uh
i think we've completely erased all
lines in this case
elijah we're told that words are violent
except
somehow burning down buildings or
throwing cement blocks at police
officers is not violence does that make
sense to you
yeah it actually does make a lot of
sense because it's all about narrative
and spinning
you know whatever you want the populace
to perceive these events as and that's
really important because
you know unfortunately i feel kind of
bad for myself and a lot of reporters
who who risked their lives to expose the
events last year
because when we were talking about
basically all the danger that we went
through all the injuries that that we
underwent and we go it didn't really do
anything i mean it red pilled some
people but
unfortunately the corporate media
decided that those riots are going to go
back into some i don't know they're
going to delete them or something like
that it's as if
it never happened and that's what
they're trying to do with this i mean
you look at all of the great video clips
that are out there
online right now showing what's actually
happening in minneapolis
they're not coming out of cnn they're
not coming out of msnbc
these are coming out of independent
reporters with 600 followers on twitter
those are the people actually showing
you the truth of what's really going on
meanwhile even cnn got called out one of
the protesters
interrupted and was like why aren't you
in the front lines why are you over here
reporting like what are you doing and we
know why because they're intentionally
trying to downplay what's actually
happening
and by the way while this is all
happening what's happening on twitter
well james o'keefe and project veritas
are getting
banned for exposing cnn for
quite literally being a propaganda
machine uh amala you
were a lefty huh we have we have a bit
of a similar history
what's going on there you went to the
protests and all that stuff i supported
bernie sanders what's wrong with us
ah i think we were just uh delusional
for a while there and i think it's a
really easy narrative to fall into i was
told from a very young age that by
virtue of being born a black woman that
i was somehow a victim in this country
and life was going to be harder for me
and it's a very
easy narrative to fall for because you
don't have to take accountability for
your actions and i think
that's what a lot of people are falling
for right now in this country and that's
what makes
black lives matter such a powerful
organization
yeah what do you think when you see you
know the big story this week that
apparently is being censored on facebook
you know the head of black lives matter
she's bought something like four million
dollars worth of houses i think
five different houses in a couple
different states in the last couple
years and she was just on an interview
that's been going around on twitter
where she basically was like well i have
no problem with it because you know i'm
using that money and those houses for my
family and it's like
uh yeah that's what we all do with money
that's what
pretty much everyone does what do you
make of that
it's very interesting how these trained
marxists love capitalism they sure do
once you get a taste of fame and once
you get a taste of money it's very easy
to fall back into the capitalist america
that you hate so much
yeah elijah since you are often out
there
do you can you kind of pinpoint when
these things are happening when it goes
over
the edge like that it starts seemingly
somewhat peaceful
and correct me if i'm wrong that usually
it seems to me there's like a moment
where it's sort of peaceful at the
beginning and then
but every time it goes over either by
design or just
entropy or whatever you want to call it
yeah there's actually a science to this
so
we've actually created uh several stages
of a protest and how it develops into a
riot
and it's kind of interesting um and i'm
sure a lot of your viewers
would like to realize that most of these
events start out pretty innocuous
and with that stage one which is the
gathering point and this is what the
media tends to focus on this is the
point when you'll see huff post you'll
see daily beast buzzfeed
vox out there covering stage one
interviewing people that are dressed
kind of bizarrely
uh and it ends up just being an
amalgamation of mentally ill people
usually
angry people and often disadvantaged
people with iq
it appears by their later behavior that
come together
and uh you know a diverse group of
people very diverse
uh then stage two what happens that's
when the chanting starts
happening uh they end up you know coming
together with their black lives matter
chance you feel the energy rising
this might also be them marching uh kind
of becoming coordinated
stage three is what's really dangerous
um stage three is the first time
that a law is broken and this is a very
pivotal point
in any protest so after stage two is
usually when the mainstream media stops
recording or they get back in their vans
and they leave
and that's what you see on on the
internet stage three is what i where i
like to have my fun
uh that could be a brick throne um it
could be them calling an unlawful
assembly and people deciding to stay
past the curfew
and it's stage four is when uh after
that first law is broken it encourages
people
to start committing more crime so people
there this is a group think in the left
they're enabled by other people's
actions just like you get a donut for
getting your little vaccine shot
and you have to have some sort of
childhood reward to get something
they feel enabled and at stage four is
when it becomes and it spreads to where
it becomes dangerous
to even report on it and stage five is
the actual riot
so once once the the chaos spreads it
becomes the standard of the event
and that's usually when police lose
control if police can't stop it at stage
four
then they lose control of the city yeah
elijah you do realize that the media
matters trolls watch this show and you
just said stage three that's where i
have my fun when they throw a brick
through the window you see what you've
done to all of us the headache that
we're gonna have
for the rest of the day hey i have my
fun i have my fun doing the job
that journalists are supposed to be
doing but they're not i think it's fun
to say to billion dollar corporations
that with a cell phone in my hand or
you know 1500 camera that i and many
many other people that are awesome that
are out there
are doing a much better job than these
corporations and that's shame on them
for that
yeah no complete shame on them uh amla i
have to ask you the the stupid sort of
identity politics
question because i feel like there's
going to be a certain amount of people
watching this going wait a minute how
can a black woman not think that
blm and anti-fur right or the rest of it
like what kind
of blow back do you get in terms of that
i get so much hate on the internet for
my views and
it's very interesting to me that people
are are much more likely to support
somebody who sits down and calls them a
victim than to support somebody who
tells them the exact opposite and that
they can succeed and that they can do
whatever they want
and to those people i ask what has black
lives matter done for you
because through the years that this
organization has been a thing and what i
would identify as a terrorist
organization at this point
they have done absolutely nothing for
black lives in fact they've been
solely responsible for the death of many
black people during these riots and
protests
so i get a lot of hate for what i say
but i have facts to back me up and
there's there's no
there's no reason or logic on their side
yeah well what have they done they got
the
the founder of black lives matter just
bought a 1.4 million dollar home in
topanga canyon which is uh 98.6 percent
white
so so they're they're on black lives
that has been
successful dlm they're doing a little
something a little something
um so let's talk about the george floyd
stuff because it's on the way like we're
watching brooklyn center
minnesota basically be destroyed right
now night after night we're allowing it
and to your point elijah
it's not being covered properly on cnn
or anywhere else
and this is what i always talk about on
the show that basically people are in a
reality war right now if you watch those
channels and you don't see what's going
on on youtube
or on twitter or anywhere else you'd
have no idea you have no idea what's
happening in the
in the chauvin trial right now you have
no idea what the evidence is or what
what the
experts are saying or the rest of it um
isn't it kind of nuts that we can
basically sit here and say yes the riots
are coming like
why don't we talk about for example like
are the police saying what they're going
to do in advance
they don't seem to do that too often do
you talk to cops that give you any
insight on that elijah
yeah that's actually really important uh
fact
factor there so the media starts to
gaslight
for violence in advance right reuters
says that the
the summation of the greatest police
misconduct trial we've ever seen
in decades that's a key phrase in
decades aka
the reaction to this should be
monumental to something that we haven't
seen in decades right
they're they're gaslighting you for la
riot level mayhem
and what happens in these in these areas
is
the police actually stand down
and i always wonder that too like this
is on a personal level when you're
seeing brooklyn center and it's like
on day three they're like we're sending
in more national guard you go
why were the national guard not deployed
in mass the first night
why is the most powerful country in the
world do we not have the ability and the
capability
to police our own cities when we can
spend millions of dollars bombing middle
eastern countries
and coordinating global wars can we not
somehow
have coordinated law enforcement at a
local level
and you know a lot of this comes down to
the fact that
the police there get their hands tied by
city officials who want this what's
called
non-interventional or non-intervention
non-interaction to de-escalate
by not getting involved just last night
at a blm protest in los angeles a video
reporter named kalyn dalmeda
for scriber news was badly assaulted in
front of 40 police officers i counted on
the live stream
they gave him a concussion they tried to
steal his phone they beat him up into
the side of a wall
and all the police stood by and watched
and why
is that that's not because the officers
themselves are
bad men and women it's because the
cities themselves
somehow allow narrative to get in the
way of what they were
meant to do which is to serve and
protect the people and i believe that
the officers are frustrated
in these cities like seattle and in
minneapolis they have a shortage of
officers
they are not they are not being allowed
to do their jobs
and we have to hold those politicians
accountable that are stopping them yeah
well
i don't think it's a conspiracy to say
that this is exactly what the
progressive leaders want
i mean this is the foot soldiers of
their party
so it's like in this case in the la case
it's like garcetti is a lefty
and he wants he wants riot i i honestly
believe that at this point i think
there's no other way
to look at it uh amelia do you think
that's like a fair estimation
oh i absolutely agree and i spend a lot
of time on social media and you can see
how all these platforms are sort of
propagating these stories and shoving
them down people's throat they're ready
for the rage
and they're ready to push this false
narrative so that when this trial
ends we see the riots and i know that
the people on social media are ready for
this to happen
they released a report on twitter today
talking about how there were several
police officers in the u.s and sheriff's
departments who had donated to the kyle
rittenhouse
uh trial and his defense and why all of
a sudden during all this talk of black
lives matter and police brutality is
this report now coming out
so i know that they're fueling up the
american people for these protests and
for these riots
and and it's crazy how high it goes
because i'm sure you guys saw the
statement that obama issued on twitter
you know talking about dante wright you
know
another young black man being killed now
nobody wants dante wright to be dead but
the simple fact is we showed the video
several times this week i mean he did
resist arrest
now that's not excusing what that 26
year veteran
female police officer did whether she
made a mistake or it was negligent or
intentional or whatever it is
but he did resist arrest but but obama
doesn't even put that
in the statement like as if he's trying
to instigate this stuff too
it's it's insane to me that we spin
these narratives as if these people were
simply killed for their skin
color or that there was no prior
altercation with the police or that they
weren't trying to resist or evade arrest
we were looking at reports from 2019
where 19 unarmed black men
were shot and killed by police officers
if you go through those reports and look
at each of those individual crimes
nearly all of them were trying to evade
or resist arrest and that is a common
factor in a lot
of these situations and nobody wants to
address it because if they address that
elephant in the room
they have to speak to a larger truth
about the black community
right and speaking of things that we're
not allowed to address you know last
night they released this video of this
13 year old kid being shot
in chicago and they were like teasing it
out like the video is coming everybody
so let's get ready
to go crazy i mean that's literally what
twitter was basically doing in their
moment section like
we know something bad's coming but then
i even saw something like i saw andrew
yang who i've had on the show who i
think is a decent
person but he even tweeted you know
basically cops killing another unarmed
young black
man and it's like if you look at the
video he's got a gun he had a gun at one
point he's not that's not unarmed he may
not have had at that moment
but again it's just this like muddled
truth elijah are you tracking that one
at all and
you think we'll get any out of that well
a hundred percent i mean the question in
that in that case of toledo the 13 year
old boy who is who is shot
is you know nobody's asking the question
why did a 13 year old have a handgun
and that's the question we should be
asking ourselves these issues not just
systemic based off of race but also
based off a socio-economic class
which can be tied to race and also the
problem is is
this is in chicago dave chicago where
kids are killed by gang members
all the time now this doesn't mean that
we can't look at each individual
situation or try to understand this
case but it's like for the mayor to
pretend like she somehow suddenly cares
about the death of a young black man
when in these neighborhoods this is
happening sometimes in the dozens per
weekend i'm gonna get the numbers live
right now let's get the numbers of
people
shot in chicago this this past weekend
let's just get the numbers live we'll do
it right now yeah
yeah cause i'm saying it's it's insane
and the point is is that this is the
this is like what we saw last year where
they they had the ahmad arbory case
where they were trying to stoke racial
tensions it didn't really pick up
what they needed for the election then
the george floyd was the the golden
ticket and the question that people
always ask
is why do they want riots and it's it's
a simple answer
these people the left the elites will
allow anything or use any method that
allows them to
grab power and to push their agenda and
they've used these
to do a lot to demonize the right i mean
the capital riots they called me a
propagandist for saying that
look like police let people in and then
the new york times releases an article
just two days ago
saying the capitol police were told to
stand down and not use their riot
procedures
why did that happen and you go well we
saw why people might have wanted i can't
prove this but some people
might have wanted violence at the
capitol because they got the president d
platformed
they could they could you know demonize
all the right wing as q and on crazy
insurrectionist
these people will allow people to die if
it means pushing their agenda and it's
sick
no i i'm with you man i hear you so we
just got the numbers so
30 people were shot in chicago this past
weekend
alone uh three were fatally shot you're
not going to hear lori lightfoot talk
about
any of those people nobody's going to
talk about that on cnn or msnbc because
obviously it doesn't fit the narrative
but speaking of the the narrative amala
when again this is the stupid identity
politics version of this
but but i truly believe that trump was
making
incredible inroads in in the black
community for whatever work that phrase
has and we know that
that you know black male support i think
doubled i think female support almost
doubled
um do you sense that like the feeling
right now is kind of maybe that's going
backwards because
because of all the rioting and
everything else that people are kind of
getting
sucked back into this this what i would
say is a blue and on
conspiracy theory what's your take on
that
i think there was a lot of good things
happening in this past administration
for black people you can look at the
prison reform you can look at the
funding of historically black colleges
you could look at the black unemployment
rate
and now suddenly we want to push this
narrative that somehow black people are
systemically oppressed in this country
which is a narrative of which i don't
agree on
and i agree with you when you say that
it's just to garner support for the left
and they will push whatever narrative it
takes
they will harm these communities in
whatever way shape or form that they see
fit
in order to garner their support without
actually looking at the real issues
we're not looking at the gang violence
that you mentioned we're not looking at
the regressive black culture
and we're not looking at the lack of
parental uh advisement in
in black communities and especially when
we talk about that 13 year old boy
toledo i read today that he was missing
for two days from his household
and his parents had not reported a
single thing and that speaks to a larger
issue so the left wants to talk about
police brutality but they don't want to
talk about the real issues facing the
black community and we were making
strides in that before
and it has completely stopped what do
you think we can do then to shift that
conversation
to family or education or some of that
stuff because this has been endless i
mean it's you know thomas soule's been
talking about this literally for 50
years larry elder's been talking about
it
for 30 years plenty of other people have
been talking about it
i try to be optimistic about what we can
do but we we are sort of in
a deep dark hole when it comes to being
a conservative on this issue because
the left has built this sort of
structural idea of oppression that is so
deeply embedded in the black community
and
people of color that it is very hard to
use facts and logics
and reason to to talk them out of it and
i think we just need to see examples
of black people who are going against
the culture and the left wants to act
like they are the revolution they are
the counter culture i would venture to
say that we are
right they're the counter culture while
they have every corporation and every
institution behind them it's
it's quite amazing um elijah have you
ever gone back to some of the cities
after the destruction and talked to
business owners
you know people community leaders things
like that about what it's like
after you know the three day three days
of destruction and then
people you know media just forgets about
it yeah 100
in fact i'm actually going to be going
back to kenosha uh this this saturday
which is where the kyle written house
situation unfolded and and i and i want
to bring that up
as an example and i i've actually been
in the area twice already and i'm going
back to talk to some people
and i've been discussing with some of
the shop owners and whatnot what what
life's like
is that from kenosha what people
remember
is kyle rittenhouse and not the fact
that
black lives matter burned down several
city blocks and destroyed a city
and that's what is the problem with the
aftermath
is when you look at a city like kenosha
a small city a working class city
mixed race pretty diverse between white
and black
you go there it looks like your middle
of america town
and you see that people them the city
got overrun
they were burning down apartment
buildings with kids inside uh i'm not
joking i
people were pushing kids out of windows
and stuff it was they beat up an old man
inside of his own shop and then burned
his shop down almost killing him i mean
this is
the brutality it's terrorism when you
wake up the next morning and you see
that the media
is focused on a an alleged white
supremacist that there's no ties to
he has no ties to these things and
they've turned this whole media
narrative about white supremacy
i think that's what hurts these towns
the most and then when they realize
that they don't get the support from the
state they don't get the support from
the government
and they're left with with the damage
with the brokenness with
the the the lives lost the livelihoods
lost i i held a man
a grown man in his 50s who just was
weeping
because he lost he had a family business
that was lost
in a night that he was around for 50
years and and so it's like
these are real people that are being
affected by this these are real lives
these are americans
and the media is so sickly bent on
narrative
and so bent on doing this and i'm going
to tell you the reason why they're
gaslighting a lot of this
like the people ask why they push the
black victim card and then also attack
white people
is because they're trying to get us to
react they want all
white right right-wing people to be like
hey white people aren't bad
and they want to get us to keep
defending white people so we're obsessed
with race and identity politics
and they're trying to bait us into their
into their reactionary you know message
so that when the time comes and they do
their next riot they can dismiss all of
us because they're like oh don't listen
to those guys those are racist white
supremacists they're always defending
white people
so they're trying to bait white people
into this like defending their race card
so they can keep manipulating the
narrative on these riots and using them
it's it's un-american it's unpatriotic
it's inhumane and it's diabolically evil
and the people that are doing this are
beyond corrupt i would say that they are
they are acting as
enemies of of the people not in a
violent way but they are actively
working against our country this isn't a
racial issue
this isn't whites or blacks these evil
people are all sexual orientations
race and gender and and you know what
they need to be taken out of office we
need term limits in congress and that's
how i think we could solve a lot of
these issues
i'm going to make note of that elijah
there are even bad gay people
i'm going to actually just write that
down for for the next show to make
i met a couple in hollywood we'll do a
spent a couple we'll do a special on
that
um well okay so to go off that though
amala when you see
you know your former side my former side
uh but you know really they've
completely gone off the deep end so it's
hard for me to even remember that they
they were my former side but when you
see rashida talib and aoc
and the rest of them talk about how it's
not that we should just defund the
police we should basically destroy
there should be no police force there
should be no incarceration
like it is a fundamental i mean they
fundamentally they want to pack the
courts i mean they fundamentally
want to destroy this thing um
at some point it seems to me they're in
there a violation of their oath of
office
oh absolutely they're they're virtually
trying to deconstruct the american
governance and how it was created and
what we've been founded on
and funny enough when i was working on
the left which was not too long ago
probably three or so years ago
we were working on campaigns and doing
community organizing around
defunding the police and sort of in
stating what they call community
policing
which obviously bears new logic and
would never work
uh but they are essentially trying to
tear down
all these american institutions of which
have served us
for for centuries so i i don't know
where we're gonna go from here but
like you said before the goal post
continues to move
especially for white people now it's not
enough to just not commit racist acts or
to say
hey i'm not racist i view everybody
equally and i judge you based on your
merit and character
now you have unconscious bias or racism
that you're not aware of
and even as i try to speak out and
challenge this narrative
i get told that i've internalized racism
and that i am somehow supporting these
racist institutions so the goal post
moves and there's really no way to dig
yourself out of the hole that we are in
and by the way you know the people that
have really deconstructed critical race
there and everything else
that is by design i mean the way it is
set up is by design so to challenge it
is proof
that it is true uh you guys probably
know of james lindsay's work i mean he's
done a ton
on this if you question this thing that
proves
that you are a racist that that's really
how out of control it is
elijah how bad do you think things are
gonna get you know in essence next week
because
you know assuming the the verdict comes
out like we know it's coming we know
it's coming and no one's gonna do
anything about it
oh we know it's coming i was just
driving through downtown dallas which
was a victim of a bad victim of the
george george floyd riots
immediately after the the video came out
last year and
what i noticed is something uh that i
didn't see last year is that at the main
entrances into the downtown area
there's sometimes up to like 15 to 17
police units
uh and there's standby vans i mean
cities are on
alert and you know we should take this
stuff very seriously
uh and i i went to actually i actually
did go to a protest um
i did go to a protest in dallas uh over
the weekend where they were kicking over
tables
you know in the name of peace and
justice and just yelling at people
eating dinner
uh and there's one thing that i noticed
that this small protest
there was like two police helicopters
tracking the unit
so i mean when a city like dallas one of
the largest cities in america
is taking something small very seriously
this means that the intelligence
community and law enforcement know
something
that i think we all know is that planned
and sustained violence
is very possible and probable in our
near future
these could be the worst riots we've
seen in history i'm not gaslighting to
then say
it will happen god forbid it i hope that
it that it does not happen i hope that
cities
do take control but when this
deliberation happens if we do not have
national guard deployed in our
in every major city in the united states
that's going to be a red flag and then
secondly
when we've seen things like in lancaster
pennsylvania and rochester
it is not violence is not sustained just
in large cities
middle mid cities midtowns around
america brace yourselves
call your city council members call your
congressmen
ask them make sure that they know what
potentially could happen and protect
your community let them know the
importance
of preparing and bracing for what may be
in our near future and play your part
don't just let your city burn
don't just let your town fall make sure
that your people in office
are aware because they may not be
getting the same sources you have they
may be
also democrat and they may be listening
to the mainstream media let your
politicians know to prepare your cities
for
the possibility of very very bad chaotic
violence
after the deliberations of the chauvin
trial yeah man listen
as alarmist as that sounds it actually
doesn't sound that alarmist to me it's
like we all know this really bad thing
is about to happen and it and it got
ramped up by uh the dante wright
situation it got ramped up by the
the situation in chicago and now it's
like we've got the big one
just sitting there and it seems like
nobody's gonna do anything so amal i'll
give you last word like
is there do you think there's anything
we can do i mean literally in the next
couple days is there anything that
that calmer cooler head people can do to
ease some of this stuff
unfortunately i i sort of agree with
what you said earlier i think we're
gonna have to gear up for what's about
to come
we have a lot of large forces against us
and as much as we can hop online and say
this is not the the true narrative this
is falsehood and they are selling this
to you
and in an effort to make you violent in
an effort to uh
throw gasoline on these fires we we just
have to get
ready for what's to come and keep
challenging the narratives in our own
lives in our own communities
and hope that that somehow makes a
difference
a little bit of hope that's that's kind
of all we got well i thank you guys for
doing this
and uh i have a feeling we'll have you
both back because this this conversation
obviously isn't going anywhere so thank
you you guys will link to all your stuff
right down below
we're going gonna let you go i'm gonna
finish up for a minute or two with the
the good people of youtube um all right
guys so
this is this is kind of where we're at
you know elijah's warning there at the
end it's
it feels alarmist at some level and then
it's like well we know
that this stuff is happening like why
are we letting
cities burn and why are we letting
politicians
say things that are so counter to the
american experience
i don't want to throw a gajillion people
in jail i don't want cops
to abuse people or to kill people or any
of those things but we're not having the
honest conversations about any of this
we're not having
the honest conversations about the
amount of black people killed by cops
versus white people killed by cops
versus what behaviors lead to those
things and resisting arrest and drug use
and family and all of those things like
we're not really talking any about any
of that they have done an incredibly
good job and i think elijah is hitting
on this
the media the progressives the machine
the twitter thing all of that has done
this incredible job at keeping the the
focus on that america is somehow
fundamentally
racist and that it is run by white
supremacists and must be disassembled
that's
what they are trying to do that is what
rashida talib wants to do that's what
aoc wants to do
don't take my word for it take their
word for it as i keep calling back to
remember back to the primaries when our
gay transportation secretary
now that that's what he is just former
mayor of south bend indiana
pete bootage little barack obama wannabe
sounds just like him there's a great
video of uh buddha judge and
obama side by side you can see they
completely like an acting class
got him to speak with his affect but
anyway he turns to bernie and he says
you want to burn it all down i don't
well bernie sort of unleashed
all of this stuff that america is evil
that socialism is better and by the way
i kept saying i mean you can find videos
of mine from three four years ago
saying that the democratic socialists
they're going to drop the democrat
part the second they can and in essence
they've completely unmasked
themselves and they're basically saying
we are here we are socialists we
are marxists and we're also buying 1.4
million houses in tapanga canyon with a
98.6 percent of the population that's
white
so anyway uh how do i do it how do i get
you guys to a to a decent place on a
friday for the weekend
well i do it with this which is just
don't add fuel to the fire
however however you can just don't add
fuels to the fire but perhaps more
importantly
you know know how to protect your your
family and your friends and your local
community maybe know your neighbors
um and and try perhaps to get involved
at the local
level so that your community leaders are
are you know in charge of a police force
that's gonna do the right thing because
you know as elijah said i actually feel
a lot of sympathy for the cops that
stand there and they don't know exactly
what to do
or they don't want to do anything
because they don't want to get called
racist
and and then what we have is all of
these places burning and you can just go
i've traveled this country enough
to know that we have tons of just
boarded up things and it's half coved
and half this
and you know it's really odd where where
are the trump people
burning down buildings and everything
else i'm not even going to address the
thing on the 6th for a second and elijah
made a point that now there's
all of this evidence coming out that
they told all the capitol hill police to
stand down so people were just wandering
in
doesn't excuse anyone that was doing
anything violent obviously
but they were literally just ushering
people in i mean you can see videos of
it but okay
but like where are the trump people
burning cities down like
know what this is and don't listen
to the mainstream media anymore just
don't listen jordan peterson actually
uh he made a point on another podcast a
few days ago that it's like if you're
under 30
no one's listening to the mainstream
media anyway no one's listening to them
so as i often talk about it's like
how much attention do we have to pay
them they're still the shiny thing for
some reason like you think if
something's on mainstream
that it we have to pay attention to it
or we have to counter it but maybe we
should just be letting it go
letting it go because what would cnn
have if not to just talk about
how racist tucker carlson is every day
like they would pretty much have nothing
else so
that's one of the things that i think
about a lot in in the direction that i
want to go and
the types of things that i want to talk
about and the ability to rebuild
something
after this stuff anyway uh have a good
weekend
get offline if you can if you want to
play along with us
uh i post food pictures and music and
dog stuff
and all that good stuff at
reubenreport.locals.com
and uh take a breath it's gonna be all
right all right see you guys